I think good religion biblical
interpretation goes best with some
common sense I believe in a scripture
enlightened conscience undergirded by
prayer every word in the Bible is not
the Word of God but the Bible points for
me to the Word of God which in my
interpretation of my Christian faith is
Jesus Christ times dictate how people
understand and see things I give an
example the Apostle Paul says slaves be
obedient unto your masters with all fear
and trembling well I understand what
Paul was saying in his time based on his
worldview in his expectation that Jesus
Christ would return soon and straighten
everything out
well of course I could not apply that in
terms of chattel slavery here in America
common sense would dictate that
historical interpretation there was a
time when we believed the Sun was the
center of the universe not the Sun I
mean the earth was the center of the
universe we know better now so therefore
I would say that men and women ought to
read the Bible within the context of the
knowledge that has been amassed and
revealed by God to humankind
at a time when men and women were first
oh there's another one
women had little to say you know the
Bible says that if a woman wants to know
anything about what happens in the
congregation she should go home and ask
her husband what if she doesn't have a
husband you know the church in terms of
the black church experience is filled
with women how do you deny a woman her
rightful place in the
the congregation when we believe that
women are as intelligent and as strong
and it's forthright as men are so I
think that we have to read the Bible
within the confines at least of the
knowledge that we have amassed across
the years and understand that the Bible
itself cannot be the end all and be all
because in my faith the way I understand
it Jesus left us and he said I will send
you a comforter
now this Paraclete this comfort of this
Holy Spirit would be to teach us and to
guide us and to comfort us so the Holy
Spirit is continually revealing new
truths greater understanding when Jesus
came empowered by the Holy Spirit he
said you have heard that you should love
hate your enemies you know and love
those who love you but I tell you to
love your enemies well that's the
leading of the Holy Spirit that gave
Jesus this revelation that completely
transformed our understanding I think
the Holy Spirit still does that and I
think men and women who let the Holy
Spirit guide them will find the ability
to cooperate and those who have a narrow
interpretation of the Bible those who
are fundamentalist to the core I think
do a great disservice to the power of
the Holy Spirit in many of our lives and
moreover the Bible teaches us things
that help us to really lay the
groundwork for greater cooperation among
all men and women even those of
different faiths so Jesus says those who
are not against us are for us and so I
argue that if I see a Muslim walking
down the street and I don't know that
he's a Muslim or she's a Muslim and the
Muslim sees me as a Christian walking
down the street and does not know my
faith if we are truly practices of our
faith we won't be able to tell the
difference
and I would argue that for a number of
religions and so therefore I go back to
the initial answer you take the Bible
and all religions best with a little
common sense and an appreciation for the
reveal knowledge of God about the world
in which we live and the evolutionary
process of our understanding who we are
as men